Remember that in times of vulnerability, in
times of chaos, in times of strife, you've
got to be really careful about people who
are looking to take advantage of the situation.
And we've already pointed out a lot of the
individual grifters selling bogus virus cures.
Jim Baker, Alex Jones.
We've talked about those claiming to pray
away the Corona virus for money.
Kenneth Copeland, the televangelist, we've
talked about all of that.
But today, I want to talk to you about a big
grift.
Those are small griffths.
I want to tell you about the big grift right
now.
And Grif doesn't even cover it.
The EPA, the Environmental Protection Agency,
is suspending the enforcement of revival of
environmental rules over the Corona virus.
The EPA told companies they will not have
to meet environmental standards during the
Corona virus pandemic.
There's no end date on that policy indefinitely.
But the one thing is they have to be able
to justify not meeting the environmental rules
and regulations on the basis of the virus,
which is very, very easy to do.
So for now, there's no penalty for noncompliance
with routine monitoring and routine reporting
obligations.
So this means that while things are crazy
with the virus, companies can effectively
pollute the air, pollute water, do all the
things that we later learn leads to increased
cancer rates and accelerating climate change
and all of that stuff.
The only rule is you have to be able to plausibly
justify it because of the virus.
Now, of course, a beautiful loophole is right
there.
As long as you can say it's because of the
virus, you're okay.
And here's the incredible beauty of it.
You can say, well, we don't know how much
we've been polluting because we've not been
able to monitor the pollution because of the
virus.
Now, I'm not saying it's not true to a degree
that if you're talking about.
Social distancing, work from home, all the
stuff.
It's plausible it would affect a company's
ability to monitor pollution and the other
video, so on and so forth.
But the question is, why is the EPA loudly
saying this like, OK, imagine the EPA realizes,
hey, you know what, some companies aren't
going to be able to monitor.
We aren't going to be able to successfully
monitor the companies because the EPA itself
is socially distancing or whatever.
But you don't have to tell everybody.
Right?
Don't tell them.
Because when you tell them, you're literally
saying go pollute, do whatever it takes to
make as much money as possible right now.
The reason why, sadly, is that industry has
successfully lobbied the EPA.
The oil industry has been lobbying the EPA
to say suspend the rules, announce a suspension
of the rules.
The Hill reports that the American Petroleum
Institute.
Big oil lobby asked that rules be suspended,
which require repairing leaky equipment and
monitoring for air pollution and seepage into
nearby water.
It's another set of grifters, a big grift
exploiting corona virus for their gain.
Fortunes are being made because of Corona
virus.
Understand that and many more will be made.
You can now pollute.
You won't get in trouble.
So why the hell not?
It's disaster politics.
One, a one.
It becomes a cash grab.
Get your friends contracts.
Trump now having the government buy masks
from the my pillow lunatic who's a Trump sycophant.
I'll tell you about that later.
Do a bailout.
But two thirds of the bailout goes to a few
corporations and not to people.
Canceled environmental rules and penalties.
Open the floodgates for your friends in industry
to start polluting and grabbing cash.
Horrible, horrible stuff.
Predictable disaster politics.
1 0 1 April 9th.
OK, next Thursday we are going to do a huge
membership.
Drive, drive.
This is gonna be a one day membership drive.
OK, we're having some issues as a result of
the virus.
YouTube revenue's down about 35, 40 percent.
So many advertisers have pulled out too big.
Advertisers of ours are either canceling or
postponing ad campaigns.
A lot of people are tight and tightening the
belt and canceling memberships, which I understand.
So next Thursday, April 9th, we're going to
do a one day membership drive to try to sort
of kick start things.
It'll be a huge discount, get notified about
it by getting on our mailing list at David
Pakman dot com.
Really easy.
More information about that coming later in
the week.
Thursday, April 9 David Pakman Show Membership
Drive.
In the meantime, make sure you're following
me on Twitter.
Let me know what you're doing.
Stay busy during the quarantine